il ya bientôt 75 ans fait lundi le 27
janvier ce sera donc 75 ans depuis que
l'armée soviétique de libérer les
prisonniers du camp de concentration
d'auschwitz en pologne ce qu'on était
considéré comme le symbole des meurtres
de masse commis par les nazis pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale
de 1940 à janvier 44 1 millions 100
mille personnes principalement d'origine
juive
ils y ont été exterminés sans parler
bien sûr des autres camps de
concentration ce soit je reçois léonce
et les magnifiques et un survivant de
l'holocauste
bonsoir monsieur thierry merci tu es
avec nous et andré l'icop directeur
général adjoint du musée de l'holocauste
à montréal vont sûrement damylkow bien
le suisse elementis qui vous est un
survivant de l'holocauste vous avez
perdu plusieurs membres de votre famille
dans le camp dans je vais vous nous
rappeler au nom de ce devoir de mémoire
l'histoire de
en 1942 la police de vichy est venu chez
nous pour un france en france oui oui
que je vous dis je suis né en france et
j'habite à deux fils de belfaux à 40
kilomètres de la suisse
40 kg mais de la main et lorsque la zone
asie est arrivé en france on a été les
premiers touchés et sont venus un jour 6
heures du matin la police de vichy était
déjà en action
[Musique]
ils sont venus nous arrêter ma mère mon
père mais de ce n'était trois enfants et
ces deux positions dit il faut qu'on
vous amène à votre au commissariat et
pour résumer la ferrand en gros mon père
a dit non je peux pas j'ai combattu dans
l'armée français j'ai défendu de la
france alors tant qu'étranger je veux
aller parler aux commissaires et ils
l'ont laissé partir de policiers l'ont
laissé partir
et finalement ils ont des prisons pris
ma mère
ils ont pris ma mère ils ont départagé
l'un des porteurs et lima elle est morte
à auschwitz au camp de concentration le
17 juillet le 17 juillet 1942 elle était
enceinte de d'un enfant de six mois que
je n'ai jamais connu alors ce sont des
choses qui sont difficiles a raconté
raconté il faut les raconter vous avez
vu de dudu du contexte actuel qui se
passe dans le monde actuel de
l'antisémitisme du racisme alors j'en ai
fait un devoir pour moi de raconter on
va venir vous êtes vous allé dans les
écoles d'ailleurs vous avez reçu le prix
gérin lajoie reconnaître l'excellence de
votre travail là bas raconte lui est
d'être à la hauteur de ce devoir de
mémoire pour sa dose extrêmement
douloureux que je suis aussi que tous
les mardis pour rencontrer des
survivants de l'holocauste exact vous
êtes le plus jeune le plus le plus jeune
80 ans
enfin pas loin de le mot de problèmes
aux proches mais on sent quand même la
douleur qu est-ce qui vous unit encore
je me sens très près de ces gens là pour
la seule raison c'est que j'essaie de
découvrir encore qu'est ce qui s'est
passé parce que toute ma vie j'ai
cherché à savoir dans mon nom ma
véritable identité d'où je viens de
comment ça s'est passé comment une chose
peut arriver comment on peut liquider 6
millions de personnes comme ça un
génocide est énorme alors je suis bien
que
je sais je sais bien que vous savez il a
dit l'air liquide et six millions de
personnes mais mon seul comme j'ai j'ai
trois enfants j'ai quatre petits enfants
je ne peux pas qu'ils vivent dans un
monde en signant antisémites et qui
reviennent à ceux associés à ces choses
là ouais c'est important pour vous les
75 yens 13 très important très important
parce que cela cesse c'est la clé
lorsque vous entrez dans une chambre ça
prend une clé pour ouvrir la porte est
là on ouvre la clé de de combattre
qu'est ce qui se passe actuellement dans
notre planète sur nos plaines avait il
dans un instant mais vous avez donc
grandi dans les orphelinats
oui vous avez retrouvé votre père quand
même c'était la vérité c'est difficile
de survivre à un tel drame
je j'ai cherché toute ma vie à surmonter
tout ça parce qu'il faut toujours se
combattre faut toujours combattre parce
que dans toutes les familles dans tous
les problèmes qu'on a et tout le monde a
sa faut toujours ce combat je vais
enseigner à mes enfants de toujours se
battre
- meyer s amélioré et j'ai vécu dans les
orphelinats oui mais j'ai été caché par
une famille catholique catholique et je
connais très bien la religion catholique
j'allais à l'église tous les dimanches
et les gens qui m'ont sauvé et c'est
grâce à eux que je puisse vous parler
aujourd'hui et je pense encore à ils
sont mort des six des listes de céder
malheureusement mais il faut il faut que
ce soit souligné que j'ai été chanceux
toute ma vie avec des personnes autour
de moi qui m'ont toujours aidé et qui
m'ont toujours permis de m'améliorer et
d'aider les autres c'est ce que je sais
c'est ce que vous faites est aussi en
collaboration avec la musique
le cost si vous êtes tout à fait bien
sûr de nos générations vous votre
mission c'est justement de rencontres
raconter cette histoire d'en perpétuer
la mémoire est aussi de montrer au monde
qui a aussi de l'espoir dans cette
histoire là quand je travaille avec les
eaux ou avec d'autres personnes comme
les lions qui ont survécu à l'holocauste
je fréquente pas des victimes mais
plutôt je fréquente des modèles de
résilience qui sont des deux grands
éducateurs auprès de nos publics et des
plus jeunes et qui sont une grande
source d'inspiration pour nous au
quotidien parce que vous allez dans les
écoles qu'est-ce qu'il vous demande les
enfants aux toutes sortes de questions
d'éducation très présent savez j'ai dans
mon témoignage que je fais par exemple
moi je vais entendre très jeune j'étais
jours de jeu je joue sans que et je leur
disais que on avait un gardien allemand
dans l'aide quand j'étais en contre dans
l'armée parce que j'étais en algérie
également et notre gardien de but
étaient allemands et comment je les ai
découverts c'est qu'il était dans dans
la douche après le notre partie de
football
j'ai découvert ss en dessous un tatouage
et c'est en dessous de sombres alors je
les prie puis-je l'envoyer contre le mur
j'ai ouvert le crâne alors la question
que vous me posez les enfants me disent
est ce qu'il est mort je suis dit je ne
sais pas avant d'autres questions très
intéressantes très très gentil très très
mal il un petit peu parce que ce sont
des enfants de 13 ans 14 ans ici vraies
histoires que vous nous racontez nous
vos absolument ce qui permet d'humaniser
en fait une histoire parce que si on
devait
s'en tenir
au chiffre à six millions de victimes ça
veut pas dire grand chose par contre
quand des jeunes rencontrent les ont ils
sont capables de mettre un visage sur ce
que
sur l'holocause de mettre un visage sur
une personne de le personnifier puis 2-2
de saisir en fait les conséquences d'une
de cette grande histoire là sur les
individus à l'appui au musée vous avez
une belle histoire vous avez des
dépositaires d'un petit coeur de papier
qui a fait l'objet d'un grand
documentaire nkr de roche et blanc de
carl leblanc qui raconte un peu
l'histoire d'un cadeau pour un vingtième
anniversaire
oui à auschwitz alors moi je n'ai jamais
été je n'ai jamais été à auschwitz mais
je dans ce club que je vois tous les
mardis jeux des histoires encore tous
les toutes les semaines et à une
nouvelle histoire et arrive et je suis
le plus jeune mais ce qu'elle est aux
enfants ont si vous leur dites qu'il
faut se souvenir mais qu'il faut
dépasser la la colère ou la page il faut
penser la paix bien sûr je dis même aux
enfants ce que j'ai fait avec la
gardienne de but
oui j'ai fait la loi au moi même c'est
pas bien faire la loi soit mais on a
fait des regrets les finalistes
oui c'est ça c'est un regret que moi de
jeu parce qu'ils et endoctrinée aussi
bien sur l'eau oui il faisait partie des
jeunesse éternelle
bon alors lundi vous allez ce sera le
jour de commémoration
oui alors vous allez j'ai deux amis à
moi
ce qui vient tous les mardis soir
justement à ce cette réunion et se
hisseront la balle sans la ballarat pour
penser vont être avec eux et avec tous
ses enfants encore qu'ils vont entendre
votre histoire et on invite le public à
venir visiter entendre l'histoire de
léon au musée merci beaucoup un homme
écope d'un grand courage merci